still seeking that 10th win yeah i think
this is a really big start
for goodie
you know it's been sitting on that ninth
win for a while
you know his thing is he's got to
establish that fastball early just like
anybody in the league
and then make his adjustments reading
the swings of the hitter
swing at the miss
that translates into any language
strikeout for gutierrez
grounded a third
small raise to tyler stevenson
[Applause]
josh bell squares one up out to right
center juan soto is going to turn and
move for third first and third with two
out now this has been a
trend over the last few months juan soto
getting on base and josh bell making
loud noises happen garcia standing in
hitting 236 six home runs 18 rbis
this one out into right field
few hops and it'll get to the wall
josh bell turning for third bob henley's
got the stop sign up another double for
luis garcia
drives in his 19th run of the season and
the nationals are on the board early
they will face eric fetty
seven and nine with a
5.10 era this season fp he's got two
starts left trying to finish strong yeah
last start on the 20th against miami got
the no decision and that's eight to
seven loss four runs on four hits over
five heading struck out five
see down there in the right hand corner
last three starts 19 strikeouts and no
walks
on the grounds there's jordy mercer
went away
max schrock on the ground
to luis garcia
make his fifth start with the ball club
little comebacker
that he'll jog over and flip it to josh
bell so a 5-3 a 4-3 and a 1-3
in the bottom half of the first how's
that for a little scorebook update for
you there you go
and he sends one to left field
stevenson through second stevenson the
left fielder gathers tyler stevenson the
reds first baseman stops it down at
third base a standing double for kyle
farmer hey eugenio suarez
first pitch right field juan soto
sprinting won't get there
skips over the fence
that'll be a double
stevenson scores
farmers in two ribbies for a johannio
suarez and the reds lead 2-1
and there's two on with nobody out for
josh bell
and now josh bell will try and
get the nats some action here in the
third escobar coming home the game is
tied
soto will stop at second
you don't want to pitch to juan soto
josh bell's gonna make you pay
the nationals have tied the game back to
back walks issued by gutierrez here in
the third and the bases are loaded for
andrew stevenson
squares this one up to center
in his bell bob henley is waving k bear
ruiz he will score as well
andrew stevenson a big two out two run
knock and the nats have a 4-2 lead
india the left center bad read by
stevenson it's over his head and he
kicks over the fence
[Applause]
hometown discount of course
schrock moves india to third
castellanos high in the air
deep center
on the track thomas that's gonna get
into your home
sac fly rbi
reds within a run it's four to three
thomas will get
already his third a b
here leading off the fourth
flies one out to center back on it is
friedel at the wall
it's gone
lane thomas
[Applause]
he's got six hits on this road trip all
of them have been for extra bases
and three of them have left the yard
he's got a good home run shot too
this is fyi it's now the nationals five
and the reds three wilson with an o2
swinging a line drive right center field
this one's gonna dunk in for a hit it'll
take it in the middle of a batting race
a mvp race on base three more times
tonight this is ridiculous he's reached
base in 19 of his last 23 plate
appearances
that one bounces ruiz gonna throw down
got him by a mile
[Applause]
boy i mean it's an instructional video
for catching right here
there's a fastball ground to josh bell
to escobar back to bell 363 double play
gets the nationals out of the fourth
inning
that's to center
that's down friedel had to hold he can
only go to third bases loaded on the hit
from jonathan india
payoff
stevenson in left field
makes the catch friedel tags
throw to third friedel scores sac fly
rbi one run game
good curve ball ruiz down to third they
got to shields
second time tonight cabaret ruiz has
caught a runner moving on the base pass
little poke to right shuttle has to
sprint wave is out of third it falls
fair india to the plate soto bobbles and
castellanos doubles home jonathan india
his 90th rbi ties the game
sent to center thomas picks up speed
this ball hangs a bit
and thomas misses the ball
suarez was over three quarters of the
way to second he steps on the bag
two men on one out
and cabrera takes his walk to load the
bases here's the pitch
swinging the crown ball back to the
pitcher speared by romero he'll throw on
to first inning over
nice work for john romero out of the
bullpen to strand the bases loaded maybe
walked and scored a run back in the
third inning
this ball squared up out to right
how far will it carry out of the yard
k bear ruiz in back to back ball games
has a home run
and he's put the nats on top here in the
seven
breaks away
farmer blasts it to the open gap that is
down castellanos around third he scores
former eyes two
a standing double
ties the game at six
nick castiano's three straight
productive played appearances
castillos
field
he wins the game
[Applause]
walk off winner to dead
center well that's how you get it done
right there
nick castellano is coming through yet
again